Hello. Hi. Hello. Welcome to SmartList. We just want everyone to know that we got so lucky that we interviewed Kamala Harris the day before she was announced on the ticket as a vice presidential candidate with Joe Biden. So we interviewed her on Monday, the 10th.
大家好。嗨。大家好。欢迎收听 SmartList。我们只想让大家知道，我们非常幸运，在卡玛拉·哈里斯被宣布作为乔·拜登的副总统候选人搭档的前一天采访了她。所以我们是在周一，即10号采访她的。
She was put on the ticket on the 11th. The interview you're about to hear, I guess, would be the last interview she did before she was put on the ticket, right, guys? 24 hours before it was announced, right? Yeah. She was put on the ticket and hot off the presses and you will see how incredibly fun and funny she is. Here it comes.
她是在11号被列入候选人名单的。我猜，你们接下来要听的采访，将是她在被列入候选人名单前做的最后一次采访，对吧，伙计们？在宣布前24小时，对吧？是的。她被列入候选人名单，新鲜出炉，你们会看到她是多么的有趣和幽默。马上就来。
SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. SmartList. Gentlemen, good day. Good day. Today is a good day.
SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。SmartList。先生们，下午好。下午好。今天是美好的一天。
Are you guys a little, I'm a little nervous about, this is, I've told you guys who this guest is because I didn't want you guys to... You broke protocol. Well, I wanted us to get our nerves out of the way first because while we've had some very big guests on the show, you look, you look ready. Okay, good. Yeah. I want to impress her.
你们会不会有点，我有点紧张，因为这个，我跟你们说过这次的嘉宾是谁，因为我不想让你们……你们破坏了规矩。好吧，我希望我们先消除紧张情绪，因为虽然我们节目请过很多大牌嘉宾，但你看，你看起来准备好了。好吧，很好。是的。我想给她留下好印象。
So I don't expect you guys to be fully prepared. I've got some softball questions. I've got a couple of hard hitters. We're going to figure out kind of what the vibe is, but I just, and this is a big week, a big week for her and our country. So I'm just, I'm stunned that she said yes, and I'm glad that she hasn't gotten a phone call yet this morning where she needs to cancel because as we will repeat when we're talking to her, today is Monday, August 10th, and we may find out today who is on the ticket.
所以我并不指望你们能完全准备好。我有一些比较轻松的问题。我也有几个尖锐的问题。我们要看看大概是什么气氛，但我只是，这是一个重大的星期，对她和我们的国家来说都是重大的一星期。所以我很震惊她会答应，而且我很高兴她今天早上还没接到需要取消的电话，因为正如我们在和她对话时会重复的，今天是8月10日星期一，我们可能今天就会知道谁是候选人。
With Giovanna. Could be her. So... Did you ever, Jason, want to, any part of you want to or still want to be a public servant of any kind or run for anything? Because I think you'd be really good. Or a private servant. Would you be, would you consider being a private servant?
和乔安娜一起。可能是她。所以……杰森，你有没有想过，你身上有没有任何一部分想要或者仍然想要成为某种公职人员或者竞选任何职位？因为我觉得你真的很适合。或者一个私人仆役。你会，你会考虑成为一个私人仆役吗？
Well, what's the rate? What's, how long's the drive? Where do you guys live? Pretty close to you. You know where I live. Okay. Sure. I guess.
好吧，报酬是多少？多长时间的车程？你们住哪？离你挺近的。你知道我住哪。好吧。当然。我想。
Can I have nights off? Let's see how it goes. Yeah. I don't really aspire to a public office, but... What about you, Will? Would I ever consider being prime minister of Canada? Yeah. Yeah.
我能休夜假吗？我们看看情况再说。Yeah. 我其实对公职没有什么野心，但是……那你呢，威尔？我有没有考虑过成为加拿大的总理？是的。是的。
Would they elect me? Sure. Okay. Let me ask you a question. What's the capital of... Judicious. Of Iran. Tehran.
他们会选我吗？当然。好吧。我问你一个问题。……的首都。审慎。伊朗的。德黑兰。
So, listen. What's the capital of Germany? The capital of Germany is now Berlin. West Germany used to be Bonn. You're an idiot. You're an idiot. Spell Bonn. You're so dumb.
所以，听着。德国的首都是哪里？德国的首都是现在柏林。西德过去是波恩。你个白痴。你个白痴。拼一下波恩。你太蠢了。
B-O-N-N. True story. Where's the umlat? There is none. Where's the ox on a goo? That's French. Any more questions? I mean, this is...
B-O-N-N. 千真万确。变音符号在哪里？没有。上加音符在哪里？那是法语。还有什么问题吗？我是说，这……
Yeah. Is batting a thousand a good average? I gave you the easiest damn... That's true. That's true. That's pretty good. And it is true also about Bonn, anyway. Yeah.
Yeah. 击球率达到一千是个好平均值吗？我给了你这么简单的该死……那是真的。那是真的。那挺好的。关于波恩，无论如何这也确实是真的。Yeah.
Yeah, no, no, no. Well, you know, it's a perfect time to bring on somebody who can actually answer all of our questions about all of this. Yes. Good idea, Sean. Okay. Gentlemen, without any further ado, Senator Kamala Harris. Yes.
Yeah, 不，不，不。嗯，你知道，现在是请一个能真正回答我们所有这些问题的人上节目的绝佳时机。是的。好主意，肖恩。好吧。先生们，废话不多说，参议员卡玛拉·哈里斯。是的。
Yes. It's so cool. This is the first time I've clapped. I'm gonna clap too. The first time I've clapped on the podcast, hi. I think you're right. We're so excited that you said, yes, my God. So honored.
是的。太酷了。这是我第一次鼓掌。我也要鼓掌。这是我在播客里第一次鼓掌，嗨。我想你是对的。我们太高兴你答应了，天哪。深感荣幸。
There must be nothing going on for you to say yes to doing this podcast. It's intense. It's really intense, Jason. I mean, people are suffering out there. People are suffering. Yeah. You know, I met you one time a while ago. You're so wonderful to have like a special intimate evening at some place.
你一定没什么事忙，才会答应来做这个播客。很紧张。真的非常紧张，杰森。我是说，外面的人们在受苦。人们在受苦。Yeah. 你知道，我以前见过你一次。你在某个地方举办了一个特别的私密晚会，真的很好。
I don't know where it was. Really special for you, I guess. Yeah. You don't even remember where it was. Well, it was like a hidden location. It was a shot. You were so eloquent and so well-spoken and so intelligent. It was just incredible to hear you speak.
我不知道那是哪。我想对你来说真的很特别。Yeah. 你甚至都不记得那是哪了。嗯，那是个隐蔽的地点。那是个镜头。你当时那么雄辩，那么侃侃而谈，那么聪明。听你说话简直太不可思议了。
And I walked up to you afterwards and I had, you're like, so if anybody has any ideas, of course, my ideas are horrible. And I walked up to you and your assistant was like, I'm sorry, Ms. Senator Harris has, she has somewhere to be right now. So if you could make a quick, I go, no, no, no, I'm busier. I'm gonna leave first. I have to go first. I'm much busier than she is.
然后我走过去对你说，你当时说，如果任何人有什么想法，当然，我的想法很糟糕。我走向你，你的助手说，对不起，参议员哈里斯女士有，她现在有别的事要去。所以如果你能快点，我说，不，不，不，我更忙。我要先走。我必须先走。我比她忙得多。
As a matter of fact, I'm gonna end this conversation and leave first. I have to go. Yeah. Yeah. You don't want to be the last one in the room. No. Ever. Ever.
事实上，我要结束这段谈话然后先走。我得走了。Yeah. Yeah. 你可不想做房间里最后一个离开的人。不。永远。永远。
What was your idea, Sean? It sounds like it was a great idea. It was so bad. I can't. It's embarrassing. Only blue M&Ms. Well, red, white and blue. Red, white and blue.
你的想法是什么，肖恩？听起来是个绝妙的主意。太糟糕了。我不能。太尴尬了。只有蓝色的M&M糖。嗯，红、白、蓝色。红、白、蓝色。
There you go. There you go. So we usually don't know when we're going to air certain episodes, that there's smarter people in our group that make those decisions, but obviously we're going to air this as soon as we can. Listener, we are recording this on August 10th, today is Monday. And there's this thing that Trump was talking about yesterday about his executive order and stuff like that.
这就对了。这就对了。所以我们通常不知道我们什么时候会播出某些节目，我们的团队里有更聪明的人来做这些决定，但显然我们会尽快播出这一期。听众朋友们，我们是在8月10日录制的，今天是星期一。特朗普昨天谈到了他的行政命令之类的事情。
And without getting into all the weeds of that, it seems to me that as brief as his executive order was, there were still obviously some salient points in there that all of you guys need to understand, read, digest. Who does that? How can you possibly read every single thing that you need to know about so that no crafty sort of like in the small print gets pushed through something that you guys might say yes to? So like, is there a huge staff of readers that then break it all down for you guys?
我们不深入讨论那些细节，在我看来，尽管他的行政命令很简短，但里面显然仍然有一些突出要点是你们所有人都需要理解、阅读、消化的。谁会做这种事？你怎么可能阅读你需要了解的每一单每一件东西，以免某些狡猾的小字被塞进那些你们可能同意的东西里？所以，比如，是不是有一个庞大的阅读团队来为你们把这些全部拆解？
Is that my choice? No, you're absolutely right. And some of these bill, now what Trump did is not a bill. It's an executive order. It's basically a memo. And so there's a whole issue with that in terms of the legal effect of what he's done and does he actually constitutionally have the power to do what he did. But putting that aside in bills, you're right.
这是我的选择吗？不，你完全说得对。其中有些法案，现在特朗普做的事不是法案。这是一个行政命令。它基本上是一份备忘录。所以就他所做之事的法律效力以及他在宪法上是否真的拥有他所做之事的权力而言，这存在一个整体的问题。但抛开这一点不谈，在法案方面，你是对的。
I mean, they can be thousands of pages sometimes and the details matter every time. So yes, there are staffs of very smart people who are familiar with the language, familiar with how a word will be interpreted based on how it's always been interpreted. And they will work around the clock scanning through and actually reading through each of those documents. But sometimes the loopholes are well disguised. And so you could see in the PPP, for example, so in the Paycheck Protection Program that we instituted that was intended to give relief to small businesses and so many small businesses,
我是说，它们有时可以有几千页，而且细节每次都很重要。所以是的，有一群非常聪明的工作人员熟悉这些语言，熟悉一个词将如何根据它一直以来的解释方式被解释。他们会夜以继日地扫描并实际阅读每一份文件。但有时漏洞伪装得很好。所以你可以看到在PPP中，例如，在我们设立的旨在为小企业提供救济的薪水保护计划中，那么多小企业
real small businesses did not get the benefit of it because they don't have the relationship with the fancy banker, right? They're not on a first name basis with the banker. They may go to a community bank. They don't have lines of credit and 90% actually of minority and small women owned businesses did not get the benefit of the PPP for that very reason. So the details do matter and what we try to do certainly and what I try to do is when we have figured out that there's a hole in it or a loophole, fix it for the next time.
真正的小企业并没有从中受益，因为他们没有高级银行家的关系，对吧？他们和银行家不是直呼其名的关系。他们可能会去社区银行。他们没有信贷额度，实际上90%的少数族裔和女性拥有的小企业正是因为这个原因而没有从PPP中受益。所以细节真的很重要，而我们当然努力去做的是，我努力去做的是，当我们发现其中有一个漏洞或钻空子的余地时，下次就把它修复。
And you must, your years obviously as an attorney, as a prosecutor, helped you that that's what you do, right? You kind of on the fly have to look at stuff and Jason, it befuddles him. It took him three days to, when he guest starred on Silver Spoons, to get through a 30 years. Yeah. These are tough. It's left to right, top to bottom, right? Is the way that the reading goes, right?
而且你，你显然作为一名律师、一名检察官的多年经历，帮助你这就是你所做的，对吧？你得现场查看各种东西，杰森，这把他搞糊涂了。他客串《银匙》时，花了三天时间才读完一个30年的剧本。Yeah. 这些很难。是从左到右，从上到下，对吧？这就是阅读的方式，对吧？
But it's not just that you have to digest it, but you really have to take it in and really take a position and understand what it is and what the implications are of every specific point on a micro and macro simultaneously, all these things. I mean, these are, and these are big issues. These aren't just little sort of trivial. These are life and death, especially like you were saying for small businesses, et cetera. This is make or break moments right now. You're totally right.
但这不仅在于你必须消化它，而在于你真的必须吸收它，真正表明立场，并在微观和宏观层面上同时理解每一处具体的意义和含义，所有这些事情。我是说，这些是，而且这些都是重大问题。这些不仅仅是一些微不足道的小事。这些是生死攸关的问题，就像你刚才说的，特别是对小企业等等而言。现在这是成败攸关的时刻。你完全说得对。
So for example, okay, so for example, the issue of the United States Postal Service, right? As you guys may have heard, that's one of the biggest issues right now that is weighing on people, which is that this administration is basically cutting the budget of the United States Postal Service. So what does that mean? So I actually sent out a question to all of my Twitter followers and online folks and I said, tell me how, if you own a small business, how is this impacting you?
所以例如，好吧，所以例如，美国邮政总局的问题，对吧？正如你们可能听说的，这是目前压在人们心头最大的问题之一，那就是这个政府基本上在削减美国邮政总局的预算。那么这意味着什么呢？所以我实际上向我所有的推特粉丝和网民提出了一个问题，我说，告诉我，如果你拥有一家小企业，这会对你产生什么影响？
Whoa. Yeah. These small businesses, they have a product that they sell and they ship it out and they say, promise you overnight delivery. It's not getting there overnight, right? So then what ends up happening? Their Yelp score starts going down because people are like, they say it's going to be overnight, but it's not.
哇。Yeah. 这些小企业，他们有一种他们销售并运送出去的产品，他们说，向你保证隔夜送达。结果没有隔夜送达，对吧？那接下来会发生什么？他们的Yelp评分开始下降，因为人们会说，他们说会隔夜到，但并没有。
Don't get this product, right? Right. They end up having to pay reimbursement for people or late fees. All of this, not of their doing. So it is hurting. I mean, tragically hurting small businesses. In real time. In real time.
不要买这个产品，对吧？对。他们最终不得不为人们支付赔偿金或滞纳金。所有这一切，都不是他们造成的。所以这正在伤害。我是说，对小企业造成了惨痛的伤害。实时地。实时地。
In real time. While we're supposed to be propping up the economy in small businesses. So the reason that they're using the Postal Service is because it is not free, but ostensibly cheaper than some of the private carriers, the FedEx, the UPS, the DHL. Right, of course. And Jason, historically reliable and historically reliable. I mean, this is one of the great public institutions we have is the Postal Service, where everyone, regardless of your income, has a guaranteed access to communication and to commerce.
实时地。而我们本该是在支撑经济和小企业。所以他们使用邮政总局的原因是因为它不是免费的，但表面上比一些私人快递公司，比如联邦快递、UPS、DHL要便宜。对，当然。而且杰森，历史上一直很可靠，历史上一直很可靠。我是说，这是我们拥有的伟大的公共机构之一，就是邮政总局，在那里每个人，无论你的收入如何，都有权保证获得通信和商业。
Not based on how much money you have, but you know, everyone is charged the same rate. And it's sort of the cynical view that I've taken the last couple of days. Amongst other people, I'm not alone in this is that, of course, at the root of this, at the heart of this is, I love the argument that the Postal Service loses X million dollars a year. Well, yeah, of course, it's not there. You know, my kids cost me money, my friend was saying he treated me the other day, my kids cost me money, but I don't get rid of them.
不是基于你有多少钱，而是你知道的，每个人收取的费率都是一样的。这有点像我过去几天持有的愤世嫉俗的观点。在其他人当中，我并不是唯一有这种看法的人，当然，这根源于，核心于，我喜欢那种认为邮政总局每年损失X百万美元的论点。好吧，是的，当然，它不是为了那个。你知道的，我的孩子花我的钱，我朋友前几天说他请客，我的孩子花我的钱，但我不会摆脱他们。
You know, that's the price of doing this is what we do, it's a service that's provided to me. It's not a profit department. Yes, I'm right. And it's part of our democracy. It's what we... And it's part of our democracy and the ability for people to transact, people who don't have the same...
你知道，这就是做这件事的代价，这就是我们所做的，这是一项为我提供的服务。它不是一个营利部门。是的，我是对的。这是我们民主的一部分。这是我们……这也是我们民主的一部分，以及人们进行交易的能力，那些没有相同……
Yeah. ...in the same way the moms... But also that the cynical point I was going to say was that this is just another arm or tentacle of voter suppression, ultimately. Yeah, yeah, for sure. ...or brazen one, it's not even subtle. Yeah, that's what they say, Jason, it's not even like subtle. It's like...
Yeah. ……以同样方式的妈妈们……但同时我要说的那个愤世嫉俗的观点是，这最终只是选民压制的又一个手臂或触手。Yeah, yeah, 肯定的。……或者说是一个厚颜无耻的臂膀，甚至都不是微妙的。Yeah, 他们就是这么说的，杰森，甚至都不是微妙的。就像是……
I mean, yeah, so here's the thing, I'm always welcoming anybody, including, of course, the private sector that wants to step up and support our democracy in any way possible. But I also believe that there are certain essential government functions that should not be privatized. And one of them is the Postal Service. The others are public education, public health, and public safety. They should just not be privatized. We do not want people to have a profit motive in order to deliver basic and essential services
我是说，是的，所以情况是这样的，我总是欢迎任何人，当然也包括任何想要以任何可能的方式挺身而出支持我们民主的私营部门。但我同时也认为，某些必不可少的政府职能不应该被私有化。其中之一就是邮政总局。其他的是公共教育、公共卫生和公共安全。它们就是不应该被私有化。我们不希望人们为了向美国人民提供基本和必不可少的服务而抱有营利动机。
to the American people. Yeah. Because if you attach a profit motive, you will see that those who have will do better, and those who do not have will do worse. So that's where I go. You know, so when he's doing stuff like this, I'm sure like everyone else sits there and thinks, A, why do we have to take it? Is there some sort of countermeasure that we can do absent waiting until November?
Yeah. 因为如果你附加了营利动机，你就会发现有钱的人会过得更好，而没有钱的人会过得更糟。所以这就是我的立场。你知道的，当他在做这样事情的时候，我敢确定就像其他人一样坐在那里想着，A，为什么我们要默默承受？除了等到11月，我们有没有什么对策可以做？
Like, can we even make it there? And the first thing that comes to mind is this 25th Amendment thing that was floated around a while ago. And I just wonder, what else would need to be on the plate for whomever exercises the 25th Amendment? I believe it's Cabinet. What else do they need to see? He's disassembling these federal departments, there's this outrageous economic disaster,
比如，我们甚至能撑到那个时候吗？首先浮现在脑海的就是前段时间被广泛讨论的第二修正案的事情。我只是在想，对于任何行使第二修正案的人来说，还有什么需要列入考虑的？我相信是内阁。他们还需要看到什么？他正在拆解这些联邦部门，这里有一场令人发指的经济灾难，
he's committing this political suicide for himself, for his party, and obviously overseeing the death of what, like one American a minute. So what else would you write in some horrible fantasy about what would need to be on the plate that would motivate a 25th Amendment? I just don't get it. I mean, listen, I think what you're speaking to are what we designed as the checks and balances in our government so that where there was abuse of power by any one branch, there would be a commensurate check on that abuse of power.
他正在为他自己、为他的政党进行这种政治自杀，并且显然在监督着大约每分钟死一个美国人的悲剧。所以在一些关于需要将什么列入考虑才能激发第二修正案的糟糕幻想中，你还会写进什么？我只是搞不懂。我是说，听着，我认为你所谈论的是我们在政府中设计的制衡机制，以便当任何一个分支滥用权力时，会对这种权力滥用产生相应的制衡。
One could argue, though, that we have been in the midst of a constitutional crisis in that those checks and balances have not been reinforced, meaning that we have seen abject abuse of power by the executive branch and this president, Donald Trump. But Congress as a whole has not held him accountable because it takes both the House and the Senate to do a lot of the things that actually would enforce that accountability. And right now, the Senate is run by a bunch of folks who are doing his bidding. And so that's why I really do go to the point of the election, which is in less than three months.
不过，有人可能会争辩说，我们一直处于宪法危机之中，因为这些制衡机制没有得到强化，这意味着我们看到了行政部门和这位总统唐纳德·特朗普对权力的绝对滥用。但国会整体并没有让他承担责任，因为这需要众议院和参议院共同努力来做许多真正能够强制这种问责的事情。而现在，参议院是由一群听命于他的人掌控的。这就是为什么我真的把重点放在选举上，选举在不到三个月后举行。
But we're going to lose another 150,000 people by then. But this is where the accountability also rests in, I think, the greatest power in our country, which is the people. The people. And the people have great power. And I think they always are ultimately the check on an imbalance or an abuse of power within our systems. And so that means getting people registered to vote.
但到那时我们将再失去15万同胞。但这正是问责制也寄托所在的地方，我认为，这是我们国家最伟大的力量，那就是人民。人民。而人民拥有巨大的力量。而且我认为他们最终始终是我们系统中对不平衡或权力滥用的一种制衡。所以这意味着让人们登记投票。
It means emphasizing early voting because I am concerned about the manipulation of the U.S. Postal Service. We don't want ballots being counted weeks after the election because it's predictable that this guy will create incredible chaos. Look, there are going to be a lot of obstacles. Let's start with the fact that the United States Supreme Court in 2013 gutted the Voting Rights Act and took the teeth out of it, the teeth that were in place to track states that had a history of suppressing the vote, in particular the black vote.
这意味着强调提前投票，因为我担心美国邮政总局被操纵。我们不希望选票在选举后数周才被统计，因为可以预见，这家伙会制造难以置信的混乱。看，会有很多障碍。首先是美国最高法院在2013年掏空了《选举权法案》，剥夺了它的实质牙齿，那些原本用来追踪那些有压制选票历史的州的牙齿，特别是压制黑人选票的牙齿。
And what happened after 2013 is in at least two dozen states, the state legislatures put in place rules that were about suppressing or deterring people of color, students, indigenous voters from actually voting. So that obstacle is here. I serve on the Senate Intelligence Committee. Believe me, and the United States Intelligence Community, Russia interfered in the election of the president of the United States in 2016, and they will do it again. They are doing it, right?
而2013年之后发生的事情是，在至少二十多个州，州议会出台了旨在压制或阻止有色人种、学生、原住民选民实际投票的规则。所以这个障碍就在这里。我在参议院情报委员会任职。相信我，美国情报界，俄罗斯在2016年干预了美国总统选举，他们还会再次这样做。他们正在这样做，对吧？
Can I ask you a question? So, you know, we talk about voter suppression and ultimately, and I know that it is across all people of color affected by it, but ultimately we're talking about suppressing the black vote. Ultimately, that's the biggest percentage, right? That seems to be, that's where the target is for the Republican Party at large. And the Russians. The Intelligence Community's investigations showed us that the Russians also targeted
我能问你一个问题吗？所以，你知道，我们谈论选民压制，最终，我知道这是跨越所有受其影响的有色人种的，但最终我们谈论的是压制黑人选票。归根结底，那是最大比例的吧？这似乎是，这正是共和党总体上的目标所在。还有俄罗斯人。情报界的调查显示，俄罗斯人也将目标对准了
black voters. Are they doing that in order to aid Trump and or whomever it is and or Republicans in the Senate because it's much more advantageous to them to have? Or is it just an ideological difference? So here's the problem that I see, and overall it is this. The government was designed to be there in particular when the people are in need to support them and lift them up and carry them through moments of crisis like this. And there has been an abject failure.
黑人选票。他们这样做是为了帮助特朗普和/或其他人，和/或参议院的共和党人，因为让他们拥有这些对他们更有利吗？还是仅仅是意识形态的不同？所以这就是我看到的问题，总体而言就是这个。政府的设计初衷就是要在人民需要时特别陪伴他们，支持他们，提升他们，带他们度过像这样危机时刻。但却出现了绝对的失败。
You can look at it across the board. You look at it with a president who from the beginning called the coronavirus a hoax and muzzled public health professionals and did not put in place the Defense Production Act to make sure that we would have U.S. manufacturing of everything from masks to ventilators. You can look at it when the president has his attorney, Bill Barr, who's supposed to be the people's attorney, the attorney general, in court right now trying to get rid of the Affordable Care Act that will, when they get rid of it, take away health care from over 20 million people in the midst of a public health crisis.
你可以全面地看。你看那位总统，他从一开始就把冠状病毒称为一场骗局，并让公共卫生专业人员噤声，没有动用《国防生产法》来确保我们能美国本土制造从口罩到呼吸机的各种物资。你可以看看当总统让本该是人民的律师、总检察长威廉·巴尔在法庭上试图废除《平价医疗法案》时的情况，一旦废除，将在公共卫生危机中夺走20多万人的医疗保健。
Not to mention the evictions. Right. And so, I mean, these are the reasons I say that we have to really see that right now the American people need their government to work. They need an extension of unemployment benefits. Democrats have been fighting for this. Well, 30 million people right now are on unemployment either because they are unemployed or underemployed.
更不用说驱逐潮了。对。所以，我的意思是，这些就是我说我们必须清醒看到目前美国人民需要他们的政府发挥作用的原因。他们需要延长失业救济金。民主党人一直在为之奋斗。好吧，目前有3000万人处于失业状态，要么是因为他们失业了，要么是就业不足。
Why do I say underemployed? Because we have a lot of people in our country right now, a lot of people who work two and three jobs on a regular basis. Yeah, it's not. We have to elect Joe Biden the next president of the United States. Yeah, of course. Of course, of course. It's a gun deal.
为什么我说就业不足？因为我们国家现在有很多人，很多人经常做两到三份工作。Yeah, 这不对。我们必须选举乔·拜登成为美国下一任总统。Yeah, 当然。当然，当然。这是板上钉钉的事。
And we have to do that for so many reasons that are about, one, correcting course around the economy, around the public health crisis, but also restoring some integrity to our government and its highest offices. Do you think there's the threat of complacency among voters? Because the Republicans are saying that there's voter suppression. The Democrats are saying the post office is going to be, you know, corrupt. Both sides are kind of saying this is so much as against us. Why bother go out and vote?
我们必须为了如此多的原因做到这一点，这些原因涉及，第一，扭转经济航向，围绕公共卫生危机，但同时也恢复我们政府及其最高职位的某种正直。你认为选民中存在沾沾自喜的威胁吗？因为共和党人在说有选民压制。民主党人在说邮局将会，你知道的，变得腐败。双方都有点在说这一切都是对我们不利的。为什么还要费事出去投票？
Do you think there's a lot of that and how do we combat that? We have to believe in the power and the beauty of our democracy and our country and the ideals upon which we were founded. I will tell you, my motivation always is not to fight against something. It's to fight for something, to fight for the strength of who we are and the ideals of who we are. Right. And I just want to go back to Will's point for a second.
你认为这种现象很多吗？我们该如何与之抗争？我们必须相信我们民主和国家的权力和美丽，以及我们赖以建立的理想。我告诉你，我的动力从来都不是为了反抗什么。而是为了争取什么，为了我们自身的强大和我们的理想而战。对。我想回到威尔刚才的观点。
Well, correct me if I'm wrong, but I feel like the broader point, and I'd love to hear your opinion on this. You're correct to me because I'm Canadian. Okay. Would you agree that the big difference between Republicans and Democrats, sort of their ideology about government and what it should be doing, that Democrats, and this is to overly simplify everything, Democrats sort of feel that government is there to help people. The Republicans feel that government is there as potentially a tool for business.
好吧，如果我错了请纠正我，但我觉得更广泛的观点，我很想听听你对此的看法。你纠正我，因为我是加拿大人。好的。你会不会同意，共和党和民主党之间最大的区别，也就是他们对政府及其应该做什么的意识形态，即民主党，而这有点过度简化了一切，民主党某种程度上觉得政府是为了帮助人民而存在的。而共和党觉得政府可能只是商业的一个工具。
And simply there's just a difference in ideology. And that's why it's hard to find the middle ground. Is that what you find mostly when you're negotiating between sides? I'll say this. You know, there are good Republicans, there are bad Democrats. Okay. So I'm not going to paint everyone with a broad brush, but this is what I will say. Democrats as a general matter believe that government should be robust enough to, yes,
这仅仅是意识形态上的差异。这就是为什么很难找到中间立场的原因吗？当你在双方之间进行谈判时，你主要发现的是这样吗？我会这么说。你知道，有好共和党人，也有坏民主党人。好吧。所以我不会一概而论，但我会这么说。民主党人一般认为政府应该足够强大，能够，是的，
help people who are in need and to uplift the American people. And you look by contrast at some of the hypocrisy around generally what has been some rhetoric from the Republican Party. For example, they'll always talk about deficits. And if you track every presidential administration, it has been the Republican administrations that have built up the deficit, not Democratic administrations. For example, even in this administration, they passed a tax bill, guys, benefiting the top 1% in the biggest corporations of America.
帮助有需要的人并提升美国人民。相比之下，你可以看看共和党人的一些言论周围普遍存在的一些虚伪。例如，他们总是谈论赤字。如果你追踪每一个总统行政当局，一直是共和党行政当局堆积了赤字，而不是民主党行政当局。例如，甚至在这个政府中，他们通过了一项税收法案，伙计们，让美国最顶层的1%和最大公司受益。
And it's going to contribute, it's estimated $1 trillion to the deficit for the richest people who don't need it. Meanwhile, in America, even before this pandemic, in 99% of the counties in America, if you are a minimum wage worker working full-time, you cannot afford market rate for a one-bedroom apartment. Look at where we are in the midst of this coronavirus, where it's estimated over the next month, 20 million renters will not be able to pay their rent, 15 million homeowners will not be able to pay their mortgage.
据估计，这将为不需要它的最富有的人群向赤字贡献1万亿美元。与此同时，在美国，甚至在这场大流行之前，在美国99%的县里，如果你是一名全职工作的最低工资工人，你根本负担不起一居室公寓的市场租金。看看我们在冠状病毒肆虐的情况下处于什么位置，据估计在接下来的一个月里，2000万租房者将无法支付房租，1500万房主将无法支付房贷。
And so what we're looking at is the difference of opinion, because what I have seen out of the Republican Party, since I've been in the Senate these last three and a half years, is it's all about deregulation. It's about taking away the teeth from the EPA, which is about saying, let's bring down greenhouse gas emissions, because guess what? We all need to breathe clean air. It's been about deregulation of industries, including coal and oil, again, same point, right?
所以我们看到的是意见的分歧，因为我在过去三年半身处参议院期间从共和党身上看到的是，这全都是关于放松管制。这是关于剥夺环保局的牙齿，环保局的宗旨是说，让我们降低温室气体排放，因为你猜怎么着？我们都需要呼吸干净的空气。这全都是关于对各行各业的放松管制，包括煤炭和石油，再次说明，同样的道理，对吧？
It has been about putting Betsy DeVos, are you kidding me, in the Secretary of Education? And to continue to try and privatize education, as opposed to invest in our children. And when we, as Democrats, talk about it, it's not about cost, it's about investment. You want to look at our friends in the private sector, you know those who are most successful? The ones who don't ask what's it going to cost, they ask, what is the return on my investment? Right. That's how Democrats think.
这全都是关于让贝齐·德沃斯，你是在开玩笑吧，担任教育部长？并且继续试图将教育私有化，而不是投资于我们的孩子们。而当我们作为民主党人谈论它时，这不是关于成本，这是关于投资。你想看看我们在私营部门的朋友们，你知道那些最成功的人是谁吗？那些不问这会花多少钱的人，他们问的是，我的投资回报率是多少？对。民主党人就是这样思考的。
What's the return on the investment? If you invest in the American people, you will win every day of the week. Jason brought up this idea of this, or the ideological divide, and what is that demand? First of all, I think that that's true, that that used to be what it is, but the Republicans have played the greatest trick, which I always talk about, or think about, which is, first of all, they always talk about a small government, and people don't know what they're talking about. You asked somebody on the street, well, yeah, I vote for Republicans, I want a small government.
投资回报率是多少？如果你投资于美国人民，你每周每一天都会赢。杰森提出了这个想法，或者说意识形态的分歧，这有什么要求？首先，我认为这是真的，这过去确实是那样的，但共和党人玩了最大的把戏，我总是谈到或想到这一点，首先，他们总是谈论小政府，而人们根本不知道他们在谈什么。你问街上的人，好吧，是的，我投票给共和党，我想要一个小政府。
You don't know what you're talking about. George W. Bush had the biggest government in the history of this country, and yet he, he claimed that that's what he wanted. Okay. So then you have, what they, what they managed to do is consistently convince the people who will benefit the least from these programs, from their, from them being empowered to vote for them, people who are going to suffer, people who aren't going to be able to receive any benefits, and all these things, and they've consistently convinced these people along
你根本不知道你在说什么。乔治·W·布什拥有这个国家历史上最大的政府，然而他，他宣称那就是他想要的。好吧。然后你有，他们，他们设法做到的，是始终如一地让那些从这些项目中获益最少的人，从他们被赋权中获益最少的人，那些将要受苦的人，那些将无法获得任何福利的人以及所有这些事情的人去投票支持他们，他们一直沿着不同的路线说服这些人，而那些正在这样做的人，这场始于，什么，45年前的保守派运动，这，这，这一小撮人。
different lines, and the people that, that are doing it, they've, this conservative movement that started, what, 45 years ago, this, this, this sort of handful of guys. This is a concerted effort that's been going on for a few generations to, to get to the point where we're at today. And again, it's a very sort of dystopian view that these guys, or that, that we're kind of living in now where they have created this, the, the gap has never been greater between the haves and the have nots. That's right.
这是一场经过几代人一直在进行的协同努力，以达到我们今天所处的地步。再说一次，这是一种非常反乌托邦的观点，这些家伙，或者我们现在所生活的那种状态，他们创造了这种，有产者和无产者之间的鸿沟从来没有像现在这样巨大。没错。
And, and it's all by design. That's what's so scary. All of it's by design. Trump is just doing a bidding of the guys like the Sheldon Adelson's and all these guys. This is by design, and that's what's scary, and that's what people in this country need to be afraid of. And the people of this country need to really ask the question which they do every day, and I think this election is going to give them the answer.
而且，这完全是精心设计的。这就是最可怕的地方。所有这一切都是精心设计的。特朗普只是在听从像谢尔顿·阿德尔森这些人指令。这一切都是精心设计的，这才是最可怕的，这也是这个国家的人民需要感到害怕的地方。而这个国家的人民真正需要问那个他们每天都在问的问题，而且我认为这次选举会给他们答案。
Who is standing by working people in America? Working people. People who work hard every day if they're working one job or three jobs. People who just want others to recognize the dignity of their work and their labor. People who just want to know if I work hard and I, and I do the right thing, am I going to be able to keep a roof over my head and not worry about it? Am I going to be able to feed my kids and not worry about it? Am I going to be able to take a vacation once a year and, and, and whatever.
谁在坚定地站在美国劳动人民这一边？劳动人民。那些无论做一份工作还是三份工作都每天努力工作的人。那些只是希望别人承认他们的工作和劳动的尊严的人。那些只想知道如果我努力工作，我做正确的事情，我是不是能够头顶有一片瓦遮头而不用担心？我是不是能够养活我的孩子而不用担心？我是不是能够一年去度一次假，然后，然后，然后别的什么。
And just standing by working people. How do you do that? You have affordable childcare. You have paid family leave. You do not try to destroy organized labor, but you support organized labor and collective bargaining. Right. You support a public education system and fund it instead of right now, which is that
那就是坚定站在劳动人民这一边。你如何做到这一点？你有负担得起的托儿服务。你有带薪家庭假。你不要试图摧毁有组织劳工，而是支持有组织劳工和集体谈判。对。你支持公共教育系统并为其提供资金，而不是像现在这样，
public teachers, when school was, you know, in normal session, two thirds were coming out of their own back pocket to help pay for school supplies. Yeah. Right? Can I ask a question about California because we all live in it and it's, correct me, it's the third largest economy, what, in the world? It's about fifth. Yeah.
公立学校老师，当学校处于（你知道的）正常上课期间时，有三分之二的人自掏腰包来帮助购买学校用品。Yeah. 对吧？我能问一个关于加州的问题吗？因为我们都住在那里，纠正我，它是世界第几大经济体，什么，世界第三？大概第五。Yeah.
Fifth. Okay. Fifth. And, and so I keep reading about, you know, every year in California, there's a drought. There's a drought. There's a drought. There's a drought in California, fifth largest economy. When are we going to figure out how to desalinate water or whatever so that every year there's
第五。好的。第五。所以，我一直在读到，你知道的，加州每年都有干旱。有干旱。有干旱。加州有干旱，第五大经济体。我们什么时候才能弄清楚如何海水淡化水之类的，这样每年就不会
not like this crazy shortage and these articles I'm reading about water is the next thing for these business people. I'm so glad you brought this up and listen, this is one of my big, big, big areas of concern water. Okay. So here to your point, for generations, wars were fought over oil. In a matter of years, wars will be fought over water. Yeah.
有这种疯狂的短缺，而且我读到的关于水的文章说水是这些商人的下一个目标。我很高兴你提起这个，听着，这是我最大、最大、最大的关切领域之一：水。好的。所以正如你所说，几代人以来，战争是为石油而打的。在短短几年内，战争将为水而打。Yeah.
So let's do something. You're a menacing resource as a daughter of California, having gone through many droughts. I've experienced this thing personally, but to your point, we need to have water policy that invests in the storage of water, right? The capture of water, desalination, recycling, conservation, and to do these things is to be smart and guess what the other thing about it is? To do a lot of that, it requires building up the infrastructure around it for capturing storage.
所以让我们做点什么。作为加州女儿，经历过多场干旱，你是一个具有威胁性的资源。我亲身经历过这种情况，但说到你的点上，我们需要有水资源政策，投资于水的储存，对吧？水的捕获、海水淡化、回收、节约，做这些事情就是明智的，你猜关于它的另一件事是什么？要做到其中的很多事情，它需要围绕捕获储存建立基础设施。
That's jobs. Yeah, right. That's the creation of jobs. Plumbers. That's the building trades jobs. That's carpenters. That's bricklayers. That's all of the folks who actually can do the work that is about also protecting our
那是工作。Yeah, 对。那是创造就业机会。水管工。那是建筑行业的岗位。那是木匠。那是泥瓦匠。那是所有那些实际上可以做这方面工作的人，这也关乎保护我们的
environment and a diminishing resource, which is water. Yeah, because I'm kind of an idiot if you haven't gathered, and I'm looking to my left where the beach is, and I'm like, wait, most of the earth is water. Let's figure this out, people. This was this weekend that you realized that, right? Yeah, I'm exhausted. So all of these great ideas, and I say great because I'm not smart enough to think of a more exciting term like the whole water issue.
环境和一种正在减少的资源，那就是水。Yeah, 因为如果你们还没看出来的话，我有点像个白痴，我看着左边的海滩，然后心想，等等，地球上大部分都是水。我们把它搞定吧，各位。你是这个周末才意识到这一点的吧？Yeah, 我累坏了。所以所有这些好主意，我之所以说好主意是因为我没有聪明到能想出一个更让人兴奋的词，比如整个水资源问题。
If we are fortunate enough to hold on to the House, win the White House, and take the Senate, can we unilaterally do all of these great common sense things? Can we do anything we want? Here's the thing that I hope. I hope that we don't have to do it alone. So many of these issues are issues that impact everyone, and they really at their core, not even bipartisan or nonpartisan. What we need to do to build back up our economy and invest in infrastructure, right?
如果我们足够幸运能够保住众议院，赢得白宫，并拿下参议院，我们能够单方面做所有这些伟大的常识性事情吗？我们可以做任何我们想做的事吗？我希望情况是这样的。我希望我们不必独自完成。其中许多问题都是影响每个人的问题，它们的核心甚至不是两党或无党派的。我们需要做的是重建我们的经济并投资于基础设施，对吧？
America's infrastructure is 125, 150 years old. Everybody will benefit from building back up our infrastructure, and that's a ton of jobs. In fact, Joe Biden has great policies around that. What we need to do around investment in our public schools, listen, our babies K-12 could give, you know what, who we voted for in the last election. They just want to be able to go to school when we can get past this pandemic in particular and get an education that allows them to reach the capacity that they're God-given talents.
美国的基础设施有125、150年的历史了。每个人都会从重建我们的基础设施中受益，那将带来大量的就业机会。事实上，乔·拜登在这方面有很好的政策。我们需要在投资我们的公立学校方面做些什么，听着，我们的幼儿园到高中的孩子们才不在乎，你知道的，我们在上次选举中投给了谁。他们只是希望在能够度过这场大流行病、特别是能够接受教育时能够去上学，使他们能够发挥他们的天赋。
These are the things that I hope we can actually agree on in a bipartisan way and put aside the ideology and just get to fixing some of these problems that are really practical. Are you guys testing yet at the Senate? You guys don't have testing, do you? You're right. We don't have a system for testing. Why is that? Well, because guess what?
这些是我希望我们能在两党基础上真正达成一致的事情，抛开意识形态，着手解决其中一些非常实际的问题。你们现在在参议院做检测吗？你们没有检测，对吧？你说得对。我们没有检测系统。为什么会这样？嗯，因为你猜怎么着？
The administration doesn't have a national system for testing. It's all, you know, let's start there. We need to have a national system for testing. We need to have a national system for contact tracing. But you would think that you guys being a, you know, a vital and essential group of workers in this country to say the least, you would think that the House and the Senate would have testing at least once a week free and available to you guys. There's got to be a reason why you guys said, no, we're not going to do that.
行政当局没有全国性的检测系统。这全都是，你知道的，让我们从那开始。我们需要有一个全国性的检测系统。我们需要有一个全国性的接触者追踪系统。但你本会认为你们是一个，你知道的，至少可以说是这个国家至关重要的核心工人群体，你本会认为众议院和参议院至少每周免费为你们提供一次检测。一定有什么原因让你们说，不，我们不打算这么做。
I mean, I wasn't a part of that decision, but I'll tell you this. I do feel that members of Congress shouldn't get the benefit of something before the American people get it. And on this subject, the president should follow through on a statement he made months ago, which is everyone who wants the test can get it, because that's just not the case in America right now. And that's why we see these surges. And also we need immediate test, right?
我是说，我不是那个决定的参与者，但我会告诉你这个。我确实觉得国会议员不应该在美国人民获得某种福利之前先享受它。在这个问题上，总统应该兑现他几个月前做出的一项声明，即任何想要检测的人都可以得到检测，因为这并不是目前美国的情况。这就是为什么我们看到这些激增。而且我们需要即时检测，对吧？
So that you actually get the result within hours of taking the test because getting it seven and 10 days later, it does no one any good because you're exposed to the virus even if you were negative at the time you took the test. I want to switch gears a little bit. What is fame like for you? I would imagine that your, your times to the grocery store have been easier in years past. Are you still doing your own marketing? Yes.
这样你实际上在做完检测几小时内就能得到结果，因为在七到十天后才拿到结果对任何人都没好处，因为即使你在检测时呈阴性，你也已经暴露在病毒中了。我想换个话题。对你来说，成名是什么感觉？我猜你在过去几年里去杂货店的时间更容易一些。你还在自己买菜吗？是的。
You are? Oh yeah. You're not going to 24 hour fitness to do your workouts, right? Well, nobody can anymore. All the gym shut down. You want to know what I did doing the virus? I got a little fold up bike and then I was using water bottles as my weight. Well, you need to stock those water bottles.
是吗？哦，是的。你不会去24小时健身房健身，对吧？嗯，现在没人能去了。所有健身房都关门了。你想知道我在病毒期间做了什么吗？我买了一辆折叠小自行车，然后我用矿泉水瓶当哑铃。好吧，你需要把那些水瓶都存起来。
But how do you, how do you enjoy that? I love people. I love people. But it can be, you know, everybody's got a camera on their phone. And so when you're out, did they all line up to take pictures and how do you, do you have a method, a strategy to be polite yet keep going? I want to see you getting a fight with a no-masker on camera. Let me tell you something and I'll tell you this about campaigning also.
但你怎么，你怎么享受这个？我喜欢人。我喜欢人。但这可能，你知道，每个人的手机上都有个相机。所以当你外出时，他们都会排队拍照，你有什么方法或策略，既能保持礼貌又能继续前行？我想看你在镜头前和不戴口罩的人吵架。让我告诉你一件事，我也要关于竞选的事告诉你。
I mean, I love campaigning. I say that campaigning, you meet the angels walking among us like people who, who are just quietly doing really great things without any requirement of fame or notoriety. Thank you. Good, good people. And I mean, that's what, back to the earlier point, that's what gives me my optimism. We can't let the bad guys ruin the day, right? There are so many good, wonderful, incredible people.
我的意思是，我热爱竞选。我说过在竞选中，你会遇到那些走在我们中间的天使，比如那些默默做着真正伟大事情的人，他们不需要名气或恶名。谢谢。好人，善良的人。我的意思是，这正是回到刚才的观点，这也是让我感到乐观的原因。我们不能让坏人毁了这一天，对吧？有那么多善良、美妙、不可思议的人。
And it is they who, you know, motivate me and listening to their stories, if I see them at the grocery store or wherever, that also motivates me. Jason, because you, you take it for you weren't going to fight with a paparazzi guy outside of the Rolls Royce dealership and I can get that for you was a seminal moment. Yeah. Well, he was getting in the reflection. I was trying to really check out the paint and I'm like, buddy, I can't, all right, here's a real hard, hard hitting series of questions.
正是他们，你知道，激励着我，听听他们的故事，如果我在杂货店或其他地方看到他们，那也会激励我。杰森，因为你，你把它当回事，你不是要在劳斯莱斯经销店外面和狗仔队打架吗，我能理解这对你来说是一个具有重大意义的时刻。是的。嗯，他在反光板里。我当时真的在检查车漆，我就想，伙计，我不行，好吧，这里有一个非常尖锐、深刻的问题系列。
Okay. Candle or incense? Candle. Oh. Football or basketball? Basketball. Fleetwood Mac or Steely Dan? Steely Dan.
好的。蜡烛还是香薰？蜡烛。哦。足球还是篮球？篮球。弗リート伍德·麦克还是斯蒂利·丹？斯蒂利·丹。
Very nice choice. Have you wondered Marvin Gaye? Oh, I can't do that. Dogs or cats? Dogs. Skying or surfing? Um, I could, you know, probably surfing. Uh-huh.
非常好的选择。你想过马文·盖伊吗？哦，我做不到。狗还是猫？狗。滑雪还是冲浪？嗯，我可能会，你知道，大概是冲浪。嗯哼。
Sean Hayes or Will Ornette? I can't say. That's really difficult. You can hold that till the end of the interview. That's really difficult. Because right now I think they both have won a series of rounds. Blink once if it's me. Clippers or Lakers?
肖恩·海斯还是威尔·阿奈特？我不能说。这真的很难。你可以把这个留到采访结束。这真的很难。因为现在我觉得他们俩都赢了好几轮。如果是我，就眨一下眼。快船还是湖人？
Warriors. Thank you. Exactly. Yeah. Of course. Well, so A's or Giants? That's hard for me. I mean Giants, but A's, you know, I was born in Oakland.
勇士。谢谢。完全正确。是的。当然。那么，运动家队还是巨人队？这对我来说很难。我是说巨人队，但运动家队，你知道，我出生在奥克兰。
Yeah. I know. It's tough. You're not a Nationals fan yet, are you? I think one should be loyal to one's team. What in the world do you do for fun? Because like, is it nonstop 24 hours a day doing what you're doing? I love to cook.
对。我知道。这很难。你还不是国民队的球迷吧，对吗？我觉得一个人应该对自己的球队忠诚。你到底用什么来放松？因为，是不是全天24小时都在做你正在做的事？我喜欢做饭。
But specifically, don't say boiling pasta. I mean, no, everything, you know, I'm always kind of exploring new recipes, but you know, I mean, my go-to, I can do like a great roast chicken or there's a bolognese that I make for four hours that I cook for four hours. So it's a full range. Now is this something that you kind of learned during COVID, you like took some cooking classes or is it something you've, your whole life you loved? My whole life.
但具体来说，别说煮通心粉。我是说，不，所有的，你知道，我总是在探索新的食谱，但你知道，我的拿手菜，我可以做一只很棒的烤鸡，或者我做一个炖了四个小时的博洛尼亚肉酱。所以它的范围很广。现在这是你在新冠期间学到的吗，你上了一些烹饪课，还是你一生都热爱的事物？我一生都热爱。
My mother was a great cook and I just kind of learned it her, you know, by her side. Oh, I love to cook. I love to cook. Will makes a mean frozen pizza. Sean likes to cook too. Sorry. I mean, Sean likes to talk to cook and he'll say, hey, can you make me, hey, can you cook? Well, you know, if that's it, my mother, my mother, when I was very young, she was like,
我母亲是个出色的厨师，我就是在她身边耳濡目染学会的。哦，我喜欢做饭。我喜欢做饭。威尔做的冷冻披萨很拿手。肖恩也喜欢做饭。抱歉。我是说，肖恩喜欢说说怎么做饭，他会说，嘿，你能给我做，嘿，你会做饭吗？好吧，你知道，如果真是那样，我母亲，我母亲在我很小的时候就说过，
kid, you like to eat good food, you better learn how to cook. Oh, man, I wish we had cooking in my house. My mother's British. So, you know, there, there's not a long list of great cooks coming out of that, that country. So I'm still trying to get the boiling pasta stuff down. That's hard for me. Yeah. Also, Jason said the same thing verbatim to his therapist like two hours ago.
孩子，你喜欢吃好吃的，你最好学会怎么做饭。哦，天哪，我真希望我家也有做饭的氛围。我母亲是英国人。所以，你知道，那个国家没有出产很多伟大的厨师。所以我还在努力掌握煮通心粉的技巧。这对我来说很难。是的，杰森两个小时前也一字不差地对他的心理医生说过同样的话。
Yeah. Yeah. No, this is, this is why I have a lot of those frozen pizza. But Amanda cooks though, doesn't she? Well, we don't, we don't do a lot. We just sort of just go around and kind of pick things out of our kid's hair. So. Wait, Kamala, do you and Doug cook together?
对。对。不，这就是，这就是为什么我有很多那些冷冻披萨。不过阿曼达会做饭，对吧？嗯，我们不，我们不做很多。我们只是到处走走，从我们孩子头上挑出一些东西。所以。等等，卡玛拉，你和道格一起做饭吗？
Yeah, Doug is my sous chef. And so we got to the point where I was like, honey, you should just like master three different things and then just make those all the time. And so that's kind of where we are. And I gave him that advice that one time that he was cooking and I was under the fire alarm fanning with my briefing documents for like five minutes, just like, we got to figure out a different process. I see a reality show in your future.
对，道格是我的副主厨。所以我们到了这样一种地步，我对他说，亲爱的，你只要精通三道不同的菜，然后一直做那些就行了。所以我们现在基本上就是这样。有一次他在做饭，我拿着我的简报文件在火灾警报器下面扇风扇了大约五分钟，我就给了他那个建议，就像是，我们得换个流程了。我看到你的未来会有一个真人秀。
I love it. Can I ask you a question? So let's, you know, let's all hope that, that, that Joe wins Joe Biden wins in November. And I really hope that you're a big part of that. And can you just make me, can you make me a promise right now that, that if that happens as a Canadian, that you'll reach out to the Canadians and say, Hey, listen, I'm sorry. I know we've been a little abusive lately, but we still love you and we'd love to be because you're our closest, you're our biggest trading partner.
我喜欢。我能问你个问题吗？所以，你知道，让我们大家都希望，乔能赢，乔·拜登在十一月获胜。我真的希望你能成为其中的重要部分。你能不能现在就向我保证，如果真的发生了，作为一个加拿大人，你会向加拿大人伸出援手，说，嘿，听着，我很抱歉。我知道我们最近有点咄咄逼人，但我们依然爱你，我们很乐意成为，因为你是我们最近的，你是我们最大的贸易伙伴。
You're our closest friend because Canadians feel very like we got, ow, like got kicked in the shin by the big brother. What part of Canada? I'm from Toronto. My aunt lives in Toronto. She lives in Mississauga. No. Yeah.
你最亲密的朋，因为加拿大人感觉非常像，哦，就像被大哥哥踢了胫骨。你是加拿大的哪里的？我来自多伦多。我姑妈住在多伦多。她住在密西沙加。不会吧。对。
I'm going to get her number and I'm going to go see her next time I'm up there. I'm going to go see her. We cannot thank you enough for, for joining us truly, really, really knocked us out with your guests. It's great to be with you guys. Thank you. What an honor. Yeah.
我要拿到她的电话号码，下次我去那儿的时候去看她。我要去看她。我们非常感谢你，感谢你加入我们，真的，你的到来让我们所有人都惊艳了。很高兴能和你们在一起。谢谢。这是多么大的荣幸。是的。
Awesome to meet you. Thank you. I'm a huge fan of all of your work. So thank you. Right back at you. Yeah. Thank you. Go get them, Kamala.
很高兴认识你。谢谢。我是你所有作品的超级粉丝。所以谢谢你。同样感谢你。是的。谢谢，加油，卡玛拉。
Thank you very, very, very much. I'll see you guys next time. Thank you so much. Be well. Bye. Bye. Have a great day. Bye.
非常、非常、非常感谢。下次见，伙计们。非常感谢。保重。再见。再见。祝你有美好的一天。再见。
Who is that? I don't know. I recognize it from your profile, but that's straight on. By the way, this is the first interview I think you've done without snacking and I think your outfit's a little bit better too and everything. No, I mean. You don't want to be ambassador. You're running for ambassador.
那是谁？我不知道。我从你的个人资料里认得出来，但那是正面的。顺便说一句，我想这是你第一次在采访时不吃零食，而且我觉得你的打扮也稍微好一点，什么都好。不，我是说。你不想当大使。你在竞选大使。
You want to be the ambassador to Canada? I would love to. I mean, or is it available? By the way, could I be? I think I could be. Couldn't I? No, you couldn't be. Why?
你想当驻加拿大大使吗？我很乐意。我是说，还是这个空缺？顺便说一句，我能吗？我想我可以。我不能吗？不，你不能。为什么？
Hey, so, guys. Wait, wait, don't, don't just rule it out like, no, you could, both of you and you would sit down. Yeah. You could be better. Don't confuse can't with shouldn't. Yeah. It's a lot of daylight between you and a good choice.
嘿，所以，伙计们。等等，等等，不要，不要就这样排除，不，你可以，你们俩都可以坐下来。 yeah。你会表现得更好。别把不能和不该混为一谈。 yeah。你和好选择之间还有很大差距。
Okay. Hey, so how about, how great is she? I mean, she's just outstanding. Yeah. Well, it was another great episode, Dan, and she was great, amazing person in Jason. Yeah, great. I love her. Honestly, as hard as it is for me to say kudos.
好的。嘿，那么，她有多棒？我是说，她太出众了。是的。嗯，这又是精彩的一集，丹，她是一个了不起的人，杰森。是的，太棒了。我爱她。老实说，对我来说说“赞赏”有多难。
Kudos. Kudos. What does that mean? Great job. That was an awesome, well done. You spell it K or C. C-U-D-O-S. You never heard of kudos? Yeah, I have.
赞赏。赞赏。那是什么意思？干得好。那太棒了，做得好。你是拼作K还是C。C-U-D-O-S。你从来没听过“kudos”吗？听过。
Yeah, no, that was a, I don't understand how we booked her, but she must, she must think you guys are great. I suppose. Anyway, what an episode. Love you guys. Love you too. Hey, listen, can I be the first to say bae? Bae.
对，不，那是一个，我不明白我们是怎么预约到她的，但她一定，她一定觉得你们俩很棒。我想是的。不管怎样，这一集太棒了。爱你们，伙计们。我也爱你们。嘿，听着，我能第一个说宝贝吗？宝贝。
Oh. Smart. What? Smart. What? Smart. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哦。聪明。什么？聪明。什么？聪明。你 这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。